yeah welcome this game to this game mega
Eric with that jaroslav zinchenko 25
something I know that's from from from
2010 yeah it might be higher nowadays
never know it's a very high rating here
in five minute mm so trying the chairman
of even though I have not put in more
work yet into this that will be risky
against the GM sorry what is my voice
doing here nowadays so yeah this is kind
of normal retreating this again after
night a for not quite sure if you do it
immediately or play castles as I said
it's been this is from my studies years
ago yes that's a possibility I think you
can go see five and take only four but
that's very sharp hmm
I think you can also castle but this is
so difficult bit more tricky to play 'if
I've 95c 49 f 4 I mean I know something
about this opening I've looked at this
ages ago but um not I did not check it
recently check recent Island
developments so put this here then maybe
getting f6 my a porn is a weakness and
possibly the default as well yeah root
g1s m-maybe move no hmm okay I wanted to
do this anyway get rid of that cramp
cramp inning pawn they're only five and
maybe I get some activity here okay I
can play Knight a four year is that
helping me on or not i don't know if i
click on or taking on here will take
with the Queen I guess so night if 595
be sure before I would like to get in
maybe I can do this anyway let's that
start here can go push of h5 that's not
really what I want okay so start with
this I'm thinking of c-5 here c5 96-94
that would be great to accomplish huh
it's not doing anything against it why
why that's interesting does he have
before trick or something like that i
don't i don't see it at the moment now
that's even with the tempo so i can
definitely go there yeah so that
position cannot be really bad for black
let's go a five maybe a four let's
really do it let's do it strange way I
think he could have found prevented my
light from coming to that that
comfortable square so a fatigues look
before the soup takes d4 that's
something to take into account 23 is not
not a problem so maybe here queen bee
form okay I don't want to play e5 in
this position and the worst my pawn
structure maybe you can go f4 f5 for a
counter play
my yes to do something if I get an A for
take on b3 then I'm just clearly better
what really not sure what he's doing f4
f5 maybe it's preparing that I guess so
I'm just pushing this Queen g6 okay
that's interesting okay yeah i know is
taking now okay i cannot move my queen
so easily Queen cannot go look a8 and
it's got to be one coming home Queen 87
maybe and queen these six
maybe a four was too early maybe it was
maybe you could maybe this one look be
one look F to know that's not working
hey but it's close and he has at least
safe now if a 4 was too quick he was he
really wasn't a bin a bad situation but
that was ever a time that a time that
badly was badly timed mmm Queen 86 I
it's got queen d sex all the time that's
a it's on 27 those kind of moves that
sets bad that's not good form a
structure we add we'd weird what did I
do wrong yeah let's not not in time
morning
oh I can take now that was just a little
trick but and it worked
ok man I would I can go a 7 ah why did I
play that so quickly I night h4s
probably still ok but Jack and still
wasn't a good idea no no no no I'm
screwing this stuff up I don't believe
it all right let's let's not be too
hectic here if I go I can promote
immediately I'm such an idiot you've
just gives me that piece yeah and and
I'm not knocking yeah yeah ok black
resigns it just gets me a piece yeah for
absolutely nothing yeah ah such an idiot
sometimes I was thinking come on let's
take on f3 and and win this within a
check here and I've got 40 seconds I can
play every move here everything wins
this point is totally harmless and now
is seven and i still can go goo kam but
by no I was kind of shaken yeah queen of
a check check my ok I don't even need to
resign yeah but ok I would have lost on
time yeah I was too shocked already yeah
it was a strange game around him he
allowed that which is weird because no
I'm oh and I had 92 winning the Queen
what is that what the game is that now I
can't play 92 I mean I already it's good
he played a pretty bad game but this is
taking it to extremes no I was I was
just thinking about strategic things not
about 92 ok I mean he just let himself
completely outplayed and yeah ok anyway
around here I had lost control a little
bit and then he blundered that piece
which still at the entity matter what if
what a bad game a 92 on top of
everything the weird thing is that that
around here he absolutely has not he
does not need to allow what what he did
I mean it's pretty obvious that this is
my idea and why doesn't he prevent it i
don't i don't quite get it anyway so
round here like is already quite a bit
better which Bishop before is of course
funny i just i was just thinking okay I
play a 4 and so on I will have a good
end game whatever and I didn't really
think about that but the interesting
question is how can i improve here on a
four because that Queen g3 move and then
takes on a forgave him gave him clear
plane how do I keep him keep my
advantage here maybe rook f6 play that a
bit slower like this and this first I
mean what really has very little that
you can do i'm completely freezing his
Queen side and that night is just very
very strong that Bishop only for looks
nice but it's in effect not doing much
it controls eight which became relevant
when i played a form later now like that
we go like this this yeah this is better
for black but it's not like a decisive
thing for sure that the engine also on
besides a 92 of course but we are here
it wants to play Queen to 2d6 that's
also interesting anticipating that Queen
g3 move and possibly going look F form
yeah this is this is a bit a bit better
then then what I did that a form of the
problem is really that after this my
coordination is a bit is a bit disturbed
because it's difficult to allow Queen g6
even though the engine wants to allow it
takes check check and then once to
really go here okay that's not very
realistic to play in a blitz game but
okay it's it's it's interesting and here
Garrett this is a bit of a problem
because my queen is somewhat tied to the
rock this route be one as a possibility
and this queen is always looking at
those two squares and this gives him the
counter play and the way it went down it
definitely was okay again for why Jeff
he just has to avoid queen takes you
form he played this pretty quickly and
he has to just look just acknowledge
that Queen takes d4 idea let this route
be one or something and then why this is
better with that a porn yeah so when my
timing here was wrong with that that a
four idea okay well thanks for watching